hi there
i'm john oliver host of last week
tonight uh we're off this week and this
is a
pre-recorded segment so as you're
watching this i'm probably off doing
something fun
like sitting in this exact same spot
waiting patiently for someone to turn
the lights back on
now despite not being on the air this
week we thought we would offer you
our fourth installment of what we like
to call lost graphics because
every week our massively talented
graphics team produces images to
illustrate jokes that sadly
don't end up making it to air and we
wanted to share some of them
with you now they will be devoid of
context but honestly
that shouldn't really affect your
enjoyment of them like this one
of grimace mauling a mcdonald's customer
get a load of those claws by the way
they went deep he's got blood up to his
knuckles so
let this actually be a warning to you
kids if you get between grimace and his
fries
he won't aim to maim he'll aim to kill
there's also this image of jeff bezos
and what appears to be
a closet full of jeff bezos clones which
is a little creepy especially as he
seems to be i
at least one of them and it's that sort
of attention to detail
that can be found in so many of our
graphics like in this image
of a cat looking shocked over something
called a dildo boomerang now
first all you see is a cat and some
dildos
no surprises there but if you pay close
attention
you will notice there's also no assembly
required
which is fantastic news for that cat you
can tell it doesn't want to waste any
time
fumbling with batteries now of course
not all of our graphics are designed to
haunt your dreams some are very pleasant
like
this one of nicholas cage as willy wonka
or this mock-up of someone who is
covered in pens and
honestly feels pretty great about it or
this one of a woman staring lovingly
at a photo of colin firth as by the way
we all do because
i don't care who you are no one looks at
that classic
closed mouth grin and doesn't feel joy
firth
has the most lovable smirk in the game
he's not coming at you with some hugh
grant smile all
teeth first and confident no colin
demonstrates restraint at every turn
from the big screen
to the carpet colin andrew firth keeps
his pearly whites where they belong
behind his discreet lips and that is why
he's not just a transatlantic sweetheart
he is
the transatlantic sweetheart now
i will say there are some graphics where
i can't even imagine what the joke might
have been in the first place like
this one of an all cats production of
rent
uh this one of me enjoying a concert to
the very
best of my ability or this one of an
ambassador
who is an inflatable tube man and look i
will leave you tonight with this
animation
of maggie and jake gyllenhaal merging
into one impossibly hot
gyllenhaal thank you so much for
watching i do hope
you enjoyed these as much as our
graphics department enjoyed making them
that is all for now we will see you next
sunday may 2nd
from me and jackie gyllenhaal here good
night